look closely
that's Barack and Michelle Obama's
daughter Malia making her music video
debut the 20 year olds former first
daughter appears in the band's new
Dakotas video for walking on air where
she's seen lip-synching dancing and
rocking out during a pretend harmonica
solo the former president's eldest
daughter looks adorable in the clip
sporting a beanie and an oversized
sweater the band is made up of four
members all of whom go to Harvard with
Malia they are seniors while Malia is a
sophomore set to graduate in 2021 but
this isn't her first brush with show
business Malia was a production
assistant on Halle Berry sci-fi drama
extent you're pregnant but that's not
possible
she also interned on the set of HBO's
girls
Malia she's an angel she was interested
in she was interning at HBO and they
thought you know what if she comes a
couple days a week to the set of girls
and he loved the show obviously we
weren't giving we weren't like making
her go get our coffee but she wanted to
do all the jobs
[Music]